je m'appelle molly boulot ceci est une
histoire vraie j'ai pris une année
sabbatique avant la fac de droit
j'ai trouvé un boulot d'assistante molly
bon ok habdomadaire se déplace au cobra
lunch tu vas métal organisé et moelle et
toi t'en parle à personne
à la semaine prochaine pour toi merci
beaucoup
il arrête de te payer comme assistante
team vire qui rêve de devenir page
arrête de te payer c'est tout tu te paie
une fois par semaine sur la partie s'est
bien passé tu vas arrêter de me payer
parce que je gagne trop d'argent avec
mon deuxième travail et si je dis non je
les perds tous les deux parce que tu
trouves que je gagne assez d'argent n'a
pas de pouvoir de négociation
tu est insignifiant je n'allais pas
attendre sans mettre un plan en route
j'organise une partie dans cette suite
tous les mardis soirs la cave est à 250
milles ça va faire du bruit aux cartes
j'étais dans une pièce pleine de stars
de cinéma de réalisateurs et d'hommes
d'affaires multimilliardaire
il faisait tapis tout le temps j'étais
la plus grande organisatrice deux
parties du monde
vous avez 2008 dans la nature en ce
moment tu vas droit dans le mur
comprenez que vous êtes accusés détenus
illégales de maisons je vous prenez un
pourcentage non continuer comme ça parce
qu'il faut pas enfreindre la loi quand
on en france que j'ai enfreint la loi
moi non moi j'ai besoin d'en être sûr
c'est possible non les lois sont claires
vous avez vu les autres noms sont l'acte
d'accusation allait et molly jusqu'au
vous êtes impliqué dans la mafia russe
pourquoi vous vous retrouvez tout seul
où sont les gens vous protéger en le
racontant pas tout
il